in news of the world a civil war veteran
played by tom hanks decides to take a
young orphan girl across texas in 1870
so she can be reunited with family
members she's never known
this is the end of news of the world
explained
when we meet captain jefferson kyle kidd
he feels like a man a bit untethered
from the world around him
over the course of news of the world
kid's relationship with johanna helps to
transform him into a man with something
to care about again
he sees johanna as not just a challenge
he's eager to surmount but an eager and
curious spirit who complements his own
desire to share his knowledge with the
rest of the world
we don't know what awaits them in the
future but it's clear from the film's
final scene that kid is a changed man
when we meet kid he's making his living
as a professional reader of news but his
job is about more than merely
reading from a newspaper he's a curator
an orator and a showman and his interest
in the kinds of stories he wants to tell
ships along with the film as he delivers
everything from delightful romps to hard
news
ladies and gentlemen my name is captain
jefferson
kyle kidd and i'm here tonight to read
the news from across this great world of
ours
so what does that mean for kids
professional future by the end of the
film he's happily news reading with
johanna by his side
but he also mentions his past as the
owner of a printing company something it
seems like he'd be very good at with the
right financial backing we know from
history that men who get paid to deliver
the news don't go away
they just evolve with the technology so
will kid evolve his news reading to
change with the times
will he go back to printing the young
girl known as cicada to her kiowa family
and johanna to her german family is an
intriguing puzzle throughout news of the
world
and yet we do get to see an arc
unfolding through nonverbal
communication as johanna shifts from
being desperately sad to lose her kiowa
family to confused and angered by her
german family too eager and happy to be
with kid for the rest of her life
still the question remains what exactly
johanna's future truly holds
given that she's essentially the child
of two worlds it would not be hard to
see her as an advocate for native
american rights as an adult
fighting for social justice with her
adoptive father's passion for knowledge
supporting her along the way
even if that's not the path she takes
though she has a bright and loving
future ahead
see all those words put them all
together
you have a story news of the world is
set in 1870 five years after the end of
the american civil war an estate that's
found it particularly difficult to keep
up with the reconstruction era
violent racism remains rampant roads
everywhere are dangerous and people are
willing to do just about anything to
survive or to profit off others
very early on in the film kid tells us
that he's part of this aftermath in no
small way having been a soldier in texas
who didn't surrender until weeks after
the death of abraham lincoln
he is a product of this time and he
suffers for it but of course we know the
history of reconstruction
what the film is more interested in
showing us is an intimate look at the
human cost
because this kid later explains he was
all fighting a war on behalf of other
people and all he got for his trouble
were some scars and the fact that he
wasn't there for the death of his wife
there was a tremendous economic
political and social cost in the
american civil war
some of which we still feel today but it
also left a more human carnage behind
psychological scarring that wasn't
easily healed
news of the world is at its core a story
of two people who have both lost their
family
johanna is as kid eventually learns an
orphaned two times over
having lost her birth parents when she
was too young to really remember them
and then losing her adopted parents at
the hands of people who thought they
were saving her
kid for his part is also without a
family traveling around and making
plenty of friends across texas
even as he refuses to go home to reckon
with the loss of his wife
both of them are on a journey of
reconciliation one that truly picks up
steam when johanna makes a choice
faced with the prospect of rejoining a
group of kiowa who just happened to be
traveling nearby
she instead asked them for a horse
brings it back to kid and keeps
traveling with him
it takes a little longer for kid to
catch up to her emotional wavelength but
the message is clear
this is the moment when she decides that
he is her family and because he
ultimately makes the same choice they
can both find their taste for familial
love again
the entire movie hinges on that choice
when she has to stay rather than to go
and it perfectly sets up the final
moments of the film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one